- Also, welche Migrationsgründe kennt ihr?
- Die Menschen verlassen ihr Land,
weil sie in ihrem
eigenen Land keine Perspektive
mehr sehen.
- Stimmt, aber woran kann das liegen?
- Sie sind unzufrieden mit ihrer Regierung.
- Politische Gründe.
Manche werden sogar verfolgt.
Diese Menschen können in
anderen Ländern Asyl beantragen.
Ähm, wer kann das alles?
- Menschen, die in Kriegsgebieten leben.
Oder Menschen, die extrem arm sind.
- Ja, im Grunde genommen alle Menschen,
die um ihr Leben fürchten müssen.
Sie hoffen auf ein bisschen Frieden
in einem anderen Land.
Aber das ist oft nicht so einfach.
Was gibt es für Probleme?
- Bürokratie!
- Ja, aber das größte Problem
ist wahrscheinlich,
dass man die Sprache nicht kann.
Und dann folgt der ganze Papierkram:
Asyl beantragen, Visum beantragen,
Pass beantragen, Ausweis beantragen.
Und das sind nur ein paar Beispiele.
Ihr habt alle einen Migrationshintergrund.
Und trotz der ganzen Schwierigkeiten
sitzen wir alle hier zusammen
und lernen zusammen.
Warum?
- Weil wir zusammen lernen wollen,
Probleme zu lösen.
- Weil wir wissen, dass jeder von uns
irgendwann mal Hilfe braucht.
- Ein Zuhause zu finden, in dem man sich
auch zu Hause fühlt, ist nicht einfach.
- Aber jeder verdient das, findet ihr nicht?